[Musique]
le poinçonneur du métro est une espèce
en voie de disparition
et si on en croit les spécialistes même
son petit frère mécanique en quelque
sorte son descendant doit lui aussi cédé
le pas à l'ordinateur
oui ce sont dix ordinateurs comme celui
ci qui en 1974 vont délivrer contrôler
chaque jour 4 millions de tickets de
métro
tous vos tickets de metron porteront au
dos une piste magnétique comme celle ci
est dans chaque station se trouvera un
appareil distributeurs manette pareil
distributeur d'un type un peu nouveau
puisqu'il s'agit plutôt d'un
périphériques d'ordinateurs en effet cet
appareil est connecté aux ordinateurs
centraux de la ratp et c'est
l'ordinateur qui délivre le billet
regarder on compose en quelque sorte
menu par exemple un billet de deuxième
classe
et voilà l'ordinateur a inscrit un
message sur la piste magnétique ce
message
le voici bien sûr là il s'agit d'un
billet d'un format un peu inhabituel les
amène à comprendre les choses vous voyez
que l'ordinateur ne sait lire toujours
que des 0 et des 1 c'est magnétisé où ça
ne l'est pas que peut-on lire et bien
tout d'abord le type du billet ensuite
la classe ensuite est-ce qu'il s'agit du
réseau urbain c'est à dire de paris bien
du rer et enfin le prix du billet
ensuite eh bien rien car c'est au niveau
de cet appareil c'est à dire au niveau
du poinçonneur que se joue la suite de
l'opération comment nous aiderez simple
au moment où vous introduisez votre
billet magnétique dans l'appareil
ce billet va passer dans des têtes de
lecture qui sont sans arrêt connecté à
l'ordinateur car ces ordinateurs qui va
contrôler votre billet ici le message
porté par le biais élu par l'ordinateur
il ya deux têtes de lecture car vous
pouvez présenter votre billet dans ce
sens là où dans celui là votre billet
progresse arrivé ici l'ordinateur de
l'ordre d'inscrire un message c'est à
dire dans cette fameuse zone il à
inscrire d'une part le jour
d'utilisation et la durée limite
d'utilisation
c'est à dire par exemple les cartes
d'abonnement la fin de la semaine le
billet continue d'avancer et passe
devant un troisième groupe de tête de
lecture ou le message est relu par le
calculateur pour voir s'il est conforme
s'il n'y a pas d'erreur et ce n'est
seulement qu'à ce moment-là que
l'ordinateur donne l'ordre de céder le
passage et le tout bien sûr en moins
d'une seconde
seulement l'ordinateur a mauvais
caractère aussi va-t-il falloir perdre
la fâcheuse habitude de plier ou de
rouler sans ticket de métro enfin il ne
sera plus possible de passer sans payer
à moins bien sûr de sauter par dessus le
portillon
[Musique]